veamos cómo calcular la anti derivada de
x cuadrada por la x de x ahora la clave
es reconocer cuando podemos aplicar
integración por partes pudiera ser obvio
porque estamos en un vídeo que habla de
integración por partes
la clave es cuando necesitas encontrar
la anti derivada del producto de dos
funciones aquí tenemos el producto de
dos funciones el producto de x cuadrada
x a la x e integración por partes es
útil si yo tomo la derivada de una de
las funciones y se hace más simple y si
tomo la anti derivada de la otra función
y no se complica en este caso si tomo la
derivada de x cuadrada se hace más
simple es 2x y si tomo la anti derivada
de a la x no se hace más complicada
asignemos entonces a efe de x x cuadrada
y es la función de la cual voy a tomar
su anti derivada y se va a ser más
simple necesito su anti derivada aquí en
esta que es la fórmula de integración
por partes y asignemos que prima de x
sae a la x asignemos que prima de x
a la x que es la función de la cual voy
a tomar su anti derivada y en este caso
su anti derivada es simplemente ea la x
escribamos esto por acá
vamos a ponerlo aquí vamos a ponerlos
entonces fx es igual a equis cuadrada
por lo cual f prima de x es igual a 2x y
ahorita no me preocupa la constante al
final incluiremos la constante
integración para obtener la anti
derivada en su forma más general y
entonces que prima de x es igual
ayala x por lo cual su anti derivada es
igual a la misma a la equis y ya podemos
aplicar esto que tenemos aquí entonces
esta anti derivada va a ser igual a fx
fx que es igual a equis cuadrada por gx
gx que es a la x x 4 por ea la x menos
la anti derivada ponerlo con el mismo
color con mismo amarillo menos la anti
derivada de f prima de x que es 2 x 12 x
x gx que es la x 2x por ea la x 2x era
la x de x y bueno al ver esto nos damos
cuenta que tenemos aquí otra anti
derivada u otra integral indefinida que
resolver y la pregunta es bueno cómo
vamos a hacer esta anti derivada y la
clave la puedes adivinar es aplicar
integración por partes nuevamente y si
te fijas hemos mejorado las cosas aquí
teníamos x cuadrada
aquí tenemos 2x hemos bajado en 1 el
grado de este mono mió y para este 2
podemos simplificar esta expresión si
sacamos el 2 del integral vamos a hacer
eso vamos a sacar el 2 de esta integral
déjame hacerlo aquí de una vez recuerda
que siempre podemos sacar las constantes
de una integral esto es igual a equis
a la x menos dos veces la integral de x
a la x de x entonces vamos a resolver es
integral vamos a encontrar la integral
de x y a la x de x como mencionamos esta
integral también se resuelve por
integración por partes aplicando el
principio establecido cuál de estas
funciones y tomó su derivada se hace más
simple bueno aquí tenemos que x su
derivada es 1 entonces ésta va a ser
nuestra fx fx es igual a equis y que
prima de x g prima de x va a ser igual a
ya la x que prima de x es igual a la x
su anti deriva de sea la x entonces
escribamos esto acá abajo
fx es igual a x por lo cual f prima de x
es igual a 1 y que prima de x prima de x
es igual
ayala x gx su anti derivada es de nueva
cuenta que a la x apliquemos entonces
otra vez la fórmula de integración por
partes esto que va a ser igual esto es
igual a fx porque de x f x es igual a x
x x
gdx gx que es la equis
- la anti derivada la anti derivada de f
prima de x que es simplemente uno por gd
x que sea la x entonces la anti derivada
de 1 por ea la x de x de x y recuerda
para que nos perdamos estoy resolviendo
esta anti derivada esto les olvide este
anti derivada aquí y una vez que tenga
este resultado lo puedo sustituir acá
arriba para encontrar el resultado el
anti derivada original ahora ya podemos
apreciar la potencia integración por
partes cual el integral de 1 por ea la x
de x plantígrada de 1 por ea la x es la
anti derivada de a la x y eso es
simplemente que a la x
pongámoslo acá abajo esto va a ser igual
a
x
por ea la equis
- la anti derivada de a la x de x que
como dijimos es simplemente ea la x y
ahora si podemos sustituir esto que
obtuvimos aquí en la expresión que
teníamos acá arriba para obtener la anti
derivada de la expresión original
entonces la anti derivada de la
expresión original va a ser igual a ya
estamos cerca al final esto va a ser
igual a x cuadra vamos a ponerlo voy a
ponerlo aquí con un nuevo color con un
nuevo color distintivo esto es igual a x
cuadrada por ea la x x cuadrada por ea
la x menos 2 veces todo esto que tenemos
acá menos 2 veces esto que tenemos acá
menos 2 veces el resultado de la anti
derivada que obtuvimos aquí que es x y a
la x menos ea la x y ahora sí a podemos
incluir la constante integración más c y
esto por supuesto lo podemos simplificar
esto va a ser igual a x cuadrada voy a
usar el mismo color
esto va a ser igual a equis cuadrada y a
la equis de distribuir este menos 2 - 2
que multiplica a x sea la x + 2 y a la
equis
más si ella estuvo hemos acabado hemos
calculado la anti derivada de algo que
se veía peliagudo usando integración por
partes dos veces